when you think of your life as an actor
and the perfect life as being an actor i
should say what would that look like to
you the perfect life of an actor is to
be able to make a living at their craft
and nothing more than that to be able to
do what we do and to sustain ourselves
and I don't know how it happened but
somehow acting got associated with Fame
and with celebrity because if you say
you're an actor then people say are you
famous do I know you and their eyes
glint could you be a celebrity could
they get close to a celebrity and when
you say well you know I've done a few
and then they'll ask well what have you
done that I might know and if you name a
couple of your movies and they don't
know them then you see their face fall
oh so I don't think it's a good thing to
think i'm going to come to Los Angeles
and I'm going to be a star I know that's
the dream it's hard enough to say I'm
going to come to Los Angeles and I'm
going to be a consistently working actor
that's a hell of a hard thing to do just
by itself yeah I think it's enough for
an actor to be a steady working actor
who gets to practice their craft and
theatre and in film and television all
these different mediums that I've been
fortunate enough to work in if you had
come to LA at 18 how do you envision
your life your career being different if
I to come to LA when I was 18 I would
have been dead because I would love this
celebrity culture so much that I would
do anything anything to be on the bigger
list to be I can feel it in my soul and
I know I would have sold my very soul to
be that big a celebrity to be a list
yeah so I'm really really glad that I
didn't come when I was 18 because no
matter how protected you think you are
insulated and grounded you think you are
once you stand up on the red carpet and
once people are stopping you on the
street and once people are saying yes of
course right this way
here's your car you know you come off
the airplane and here's the person with
that stuff starts to build up in you and
you start to feel I deserve that and so
it's really really good to have the kick
in your pants or not being on the list
or thinking you're going to get the
pilot but you don't get it because
somebody more famous was hired there's a
good things because they rate that make
you reach the crossroads and the
question is how famous do I want to be
and what will I sacrifice to get there
and for me I would have told you before
I came to LA I want to be very famous
and I'd sacrifice anything but it's not
true it's not true it's not worth my
family fame is not worth my
relationships fame is not worth my
relationship with God famous not worth
my heart the heart of an actor which has
to stay open I can't close it off so i'm
happy with my little tiny level of
celebrity I do my theater i do my films
like this one and you know something big
ever happens that's great that's great
but i'm not seeking it I'm not seeking
it anymore and if I never do another red
carpet you know it's okay oh yeah it's
okay so you went back home for a while
after the we'll call it the inciting
incident which was one of the two red
carpet things yeah and you contemplated
giving up acting yeah so how much time
did you kind of give yourself and then
what conclusion did you come up with I
know you said you really want to do
theatre and you are you I think you're
doing something in Pasadena coming up
but what was the process like I can to
funk for about four months after you
know this constant drone of
you're a little bit famous but you need
to be more famous and what can we do to
get you more famous and maybe we could
you know I had discussions with
publicist well maybe we could do a
scandal all right you know what can we
do what can we do that's going to go
viral what can we do this going to go
viral and yeah I got a bad funk for
about three months and I just went back
east and walked on the beach and you
know didn't want to talk to anybody and
being around real people is very good so
if you're in la actor it's a really good
thing I know you we don't want to leave
LA because you if you leave you feel
like you're missing something you're not
missing anything take a break go back
pet dogs be with real people whose life
doesn't revolve around being on the list
and then you can get some sense of what
it is you want to do and what the sense
that I got after taking that time was
that I don't want or need to be a star
or a celebrity I love what I do for a
living and I love it with a passion and
I want to do it and I'll do whatever
publicity is necessary to promote my
projects I love doing that publicity
about things I care about but I'm not
going to say hey look at me hey look at
me hey look at me and then be pissed
because that persons not looking to me
although all these other people I'm not
going to do that anymore I don't want to
be important anymore I have to wake up
every day and look in the mirror and say
it's okay if you're not important it's
okay if you're not a star it's okay if
people don't know who you are you're an
actor you're an actor and that's enough
you